[Musica]
oh my boys l'impostore pani j
ok amen è da una vita che stiamo recando
è la prima volta di un impostore sono
molto emozionato mi fanno uccidere tipo
istantaneamente
allora proviamo a fare la tasche teen
electrical e per farlo devo fare accussì
ho fatto già una cazzata già sbagliato
già stato sbagliato ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato ho sbagliato
google ha ucciso qualcuno
qualcuno avventato ragazzi ho visto ho
visto qualcuno ventare ma non ho visto
che uno di fianco all'altro quindi noi
non eravamo ho visto ho visto la ventola
che si apriva e col sparito riportato
nell elettrica dalla capita di fare più
nell'angolino
io ricordo che era per me no io confermo
perché era appena 6 sì non ho visto
nessuno usciva alla re rimasta dentro la
mente dei ragazzi abbiamo importanti
questa partita davvero mica erariale
ottica li ho io mica di tool pro
giochiamola giochiamocela bene lega
perché questa mi piace questa una bella
partita il marxismo chiamarci perfetto
la vediamo cosa dobbiamo fare march
march gli anni faceva una doppia
facciamo una doppia facciamo una doppia
c'è una doppia c'è una doppia 654 chiude
le porte no le porte da un chiudere a
cacchio perfetto vai penta lenta
bellissima ciò che non ci sia nessuno a
camere non c'e nessuna camera attenzione
ok cioè trovavo le porta ad hoc che alla
miseria ragazzi io sto zitto perché
quando farlo faccio da anni sto zitto e
basta so sto zitto ragazzi ecco questo
lo dirà allora march ce la stiamo
giocando da dio
vediamo di continuarla così voglio
andare in due voglio mandare i due ad
agno in due rai perché facciamo fuori
fare e marzi uso occhio perché ci stiamo
inseguendo vai vai vai ma sempre qua se
prima elettrica
lasciamo che marx continui allora
volendo possiamo far fuori aspetta far
fuori qualcuno se lo vedi far fuori
qualcuno se questo si è poi qualcuno che
poi qualcuno che qualcuno vorrebbe
qualcuno stesse qua oddio partecipanti
self orco demonio
praga gianicolo ha fatto in tempo a
vederlo
ragazzi io e marci siamo secondo me è un
ottimo team perché lui capisce
esattamente quello che penso per me è
perfetto come come teammate ragazzi
adesso il momento tanto fermarci capisce
quello che pensa il momento di fare la
doppia bisogna fare la doppia quindi
arriviamo vicino al qualcuno e si secca
anzi sempre fare tutte e due
tutte to play as one two player sua
vittoria
two player su juan vittoria si fa così
fidati weimar ci fa ma la doppia fame la
fame la fame la fame la favola
una notte da tre step ok quindi io vado
qua tu fai sempre cucinate dai doveste
faccia ma perché mi è vicino vabbè vabbè
che cosa vuoi fare devi fare marci
bisogna fare march marci lo facciamo
marci
cosa vuoi fare march dimmi dimmi dimmi
dimmi dimmi parlami cosa c'è io volevo
fare la doppia premi sono spariti tutti
ok a cena madonna bruttissima basta che
si avvicini una persona ed è fatta
teoricamente brest in uno dovrebbe
andare al security a far fuori dall
altro ok e facciamo la facciamo la palla
alla falla fighter f f
ok la posta beh non capivo cosa se non
ho capito ho capito lancia nessuno
[Musica]
siamo tutti ma donna che stava papà di
mettere ansia ogni volta non so perché
lampada disegnata dalla d'oro insomma
che si chiama lounge bar
anyway allora andiamo per prima cosa gli
incastri tiria devo assolutamente
prendere dalla 4 set
adesso sì che siamo a posto è già morto
qualcuno dopo neve è massima perché hai
marzo buongiorno ho trovato in admin il
corpo bianco
ok ok allora potete mettere m francese
in 600 per cento perché avevamo proprio
allo start e fermi però secondo il
pastore può essere secondo impostare
ragione viene inutile
niente script php perl bravi giunti a
questo è morto di portare nate morte
grazie a pronti è morto qualcuno è morto
nat hi hi vision ott
l'impasto rabboccato ragazzi bit caci la
radica c e io mi sono fatto una cagata
perché potevano tornare dietro a vedere
chi era innocente ma non l'ho fatto e
che poi magari non ho visto niente ho
solo visto che compri nato in prima di
della decontaminazione per andare su una
micro noi siamo ok ok io stavo con un
altro in green house non so chi fosse
priorità
io sto scappando di paga non siamo
capaci di giocare questi giorni non
d'accordo ma chi è che la controllata
domenico non è non sognava che rigore no
no unico per forza sono io
raga non so che dirvi non ho idea vedo
solo corpi a caso morti secondo me
adesso mista con la trota voglio io
scommettete ora marci vorrei stare con
gli altri per vedere se le scarpe care
un indiziato e praga ma sono è sempre
marcirà march che sale a che non
marcelli malati che cacchio sta facendo
ragazzi march non sta facendo niente sta
girando a caso march mi segue e marci
sicuro raga ma imposto lo ha fatto una
genialata clamorosa kill davanti al
reattore del verde chiaro
unico punto il mio stava dall'altra
basta fare i minerali e sono sceso e
celava la morte quindi 20 20 per forza
per me questo può bastare
ok non so chi avete votato lui abbiamo
interpretato in maniera molto differente
gli indizi veniamo ero io ma basta la
storia
ero io ma ma non per colpe non l'ha
uccisa lui
mannaggia da basta basta farci impostare
basta secondo me i ragazzi veramente
potrebbe essere esterni non sto
scherzando perché no no no franci cosa
non può essere franci cosa è fare sono
puliti franci co.se.r sono puliti quindi
io però mi sta seguendo spetta né
seguito no ok franci cose sempre sono
questi step non mi convince adesso c'è
un morto quanto ci fate c'era stesso
equa ma lei c'è un morto
centro tempo ad un orto franciso eccolo
paste franci koso free io ho marzo e per
me e ho finito
no aspetta di fallito o fili aspetta a
rivotare presidi come mentre servivamo
di nuovo giusto si ok quindi dove
trovato il corpo fa vi ho trovato a
sinistra ok perfetto allora non so se
con l'evento poteva essere di nuovo con
franci quando è favorito atto il corpo
ma sarebbe strano ricorrere verso il
corpo e quindi francese d'accordo
fatto sta che io mentre andavo via dalla
contaminazione ha visto marcus alla
destra di contamination sono andato via
e ferì invece andava e magicamente morta
ma qualcosa io ero a fare la task vicino
sulla alla v però la parte di destra
trofei che proprio bravi ragazzi
ogni volta che guardavo degeneri da
qualche altra parte lo marinai pensa che
sono tornato indietro ha detto fini che
trovo un colpo dell'estate c'era il
corpo dove c'è di tutto incredibile
[Musica]